asking a cute girl to meet you down by
the tracks Harper good thing Z and I are
tight I have to show you something easy
there tiger
hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
arrow Slade finally put on the costume
Oliver made Roy an offer he could not
refuse and as the title of the episode
implies blind spot everyone is missing
the giant Deathstroke shaped warning
sign also big heads up I'm doing Q&A
videos for all the rest of the arrow
episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you have any arrow or
flash related questions just put them in
the comments if you want me to put it in
that video so careful for spoilers from
this episode if you haven't seen it yet
because we'll be talking about specific
plot points but let's do our top 5
moments and then I'll do my review
number 5 brother blood kills his mother
I knew he was going to kill her just
because the scene was so creepy I don't
know why he had to go out in the hall to
put the mask on though there weren't any
cameras so it had nothing to do with
hiding his identity I think he's really
just drunk his own kool-aid and puts the
mask on to become the brother blood
character we haven't gotten a really
explicit explanation of what his
philosophy is but I'm expecting Oliver
to trap him in a classic evil guy
monologue where he explains everything
in the comics brother blood killed both
of his parents so I guess it was only a
matter of time before he killed his
mother - Slade has this really strict
sense of justice so eventually brother
blood does get bitch-slapped I would
have been happier if Slade had just
stabbed him through the hand instead of
just killing all his men though I feel
like that would have been more
satisfying number 4 Laurel goes off the
deep end the laurel arc this season is
basically her flushing herself down the
toilet
which is why you see her inhaling all
those pills I think she's been taking
oxy Quentin says that she tested
positive for opiates and she stole pills
from him it's a little after-school
special but I think it's a good way to
explain why her character has been so
off-putting this season plus her trip to
Skid Row in the next couple of episodes
is how Oliver convinces Black Canary to
come back which in turn will bring the
Nyssa al Ghul character so when Laurel
takes a dump on herself by flushing her
life down the toilet she's really taking
a dump on all the other characters
because it brings down the League of
Assassins on them and thus the shitstorm
begins
number three Ivo turns on Sara back on
the island I really thought Ivo was
going to confess some crazy Amazo plot
that went way beyond the mirakuru serum
but he really just went crazy in the
comics he has this phobia of death so
that could explain why he was acting so
crazy on the CB radio whenever he was
talking on the radio and the camera was
in really close
on his face and he looked really tense I
expected it to pull back and show Slade
with a giant knife on his throat but
Slade has been m.i.a since he ran off
still so eventually he has to show up on
that boat number two this is a funny one
Roy and since date night I am so happy
that it's in his back I love her
character in my mind she's the more
interesting version of Thea I'll
definitely have to add date night in the
Calathes to my bucket list though that
looked like a lot of fun I'm always
impressed with this stunt work on arrow
so Roy super dropkick over the car
looked really good it was also really
funny seeing what Thea ended up giving
cent to where she almost looked like a
dominatrix
so I kind of expected her to pull the
knife on the guy in the car I will say
that after Roy revealed his powers to
her earlier in the episode I started
chipping them hardcore I know the
writers really want us to like Fiat but
don't you feel like Roy and CIN could
have their own spin-off show you could
just call it red sin and it would be the
two of them going all Marvel Punisher on
people in the glades that boasts ad
campaign that was running the blood rush
shorts that would have been so much more
fun if it had been Roy and sin she's
like Roy's felicity even though we're
supposed to think that Thea is like
Roy's Felicity I keep wanting to see
them hook up but I don't think it's
gonna happen this season and I'm praying
that they do not kill sin in my number
one moment no surprises here Slade in
full-on Deathstroke armor for the first
time we saw it in last week's teaser so
I kept expecting him to jump into that
final fight in the cannery
but in case you missed it his
Deathstroke outfit is an amalgam of the
new 52 version from the comics and the
version in the animated movies son of
Batman I don't think the show will give
him the special ABEO blade or any of the
crazier stuff that he has in the comic
books it was so satisfying to see him
fly across screen slicing up brother
Bloods men it's just meant to show us
that there is no way Oliver's going to
be able to beat him on his own in the
comics Deathstroke has been able to
fight off the entire Justice League at
the same time that's Green Arrow
Superman Wonder Woman the flash Green
Lantern all at the same time that means
that on arrow on the show Oliver Roy and
black Canary will all have to take him
on at the same time think about how
awesome that fight is going to be it
probably will not come until the finale
let me know what your favorite moment
was in the comments below I know I know
we're all thinking the same thing Slade
has to have his own spin-off show that
would be so awesome overall I loved the
episode the mid-season finale continues
to be my favorite but I am definitely
expecting the finale to
eat that one thing that arrow has done
really well in the past and continues to
do is develop his character so well that
they could sustain their own shows by
themselves not just Barry Allen and I'm
talking about Roy Anson Slade
even Black Canary is almost there that
is one character that I think needs some
more context though I think we're gonna
get that in the next League of Assassins
episode heir to the demon
that's episode 13 which will be
happening in two weeks I think is going
to take Sarah dying and Laurel taking up
the mantle of Black Canary for that
character to start being interesting and
there's no way to know if that's gonna
happen this season if ever they might
just keep the Sarah Lance character on
the show
indefinitely quick spin-off announcement
though they have started to make casting
announcements for the flash TV pilot so
I'll be doing a separate video for that
in the next couple of weeks be sure to
subscribe to get it
don't forget tomorrow I'll be posting my
arrow Q&A video for this episode so any
flash and the arrow questions you have
just post them in the comments and I'll
pick from those and put them in the
video right now click here for last
week's episode of arrow and click here
for my review of black sails
it's like Assassin's Creed Black Flag
meets Treasure Island trust me you will
like it it's a lot of fun thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you